advice from walt disney on finding your  passion  as seen in zugu101 when you believe a  thing  believe in it all the way implicitly and  unquestionably  we didn't go into disneyland just with  the idea of making money  we did it in the knowledge that most of  the people i talked to  thought it would be a financial disaster  closed and forgotten within the first  year  when we opened disneyland a lot of  people got the impression that it was a  get rich quick thing  but they didn't realize that behind  disneyland was this great  organization that i built here at the  studio and they all got into it and we  were doing it because we  loved to do it when you're curious  you find lots of interesting things to  do and one thing it takes to accomplish  something is courage  if you can dream it you can do it  to learn more check out zugo 101 in the  link below